- [Host] Now, please
welcome, Mr. Gary Vee!
(attendees applauding and cheering)
♪ Too many things a day ♪
- [Gary] What up?
♪ You make me think today ♪
- Thank you.
Thank you, Manila.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
(attendees applauding and cheering)
Thank you.
Sit, sit, thank you.
Thank you so much.
Thank you, thank you.
Sit, sit, sit.
Thank you.
- [Attendee] I love you!
- I love you back.
I mean we could do this the whole time.
I don't give a fuck.
(attendees applauding and cheering)
I'll just stand here listen to you.
Sit, sit, sit.
All right.
Let's sit down, let's do this.
So thank you for having me.
I'm super excited to be here.
There's a lot of different
things I wanna cover.
I'm super excited about the format.
I hear we're gonna be doing
the VIP Q and A up here
which I'm super excited about.
So I'm looking forward to that part.
For me, it's been a pretty exciting
last couple days of touring through Asia.
I've given a couple speeches
and a bunch of different themes
are popping up and I think in general,
I'm spending a lot of
time trying to figure out
how do I bring the most
value to a conference?
What's going through the
mindset of the individuals?
Why are you even here
on a Sunday afternoon?
What can I bring value in a world
where so much of the
content that I'm putting out
is widely free, like
what what's this about?
Obviously, it's fun to do it live
and it's fun for me to visit the region
and I'm very humbled to be here
but I think, for me, I'm trying to think
about the take homes and
it's really interesting.
I have a sneaker coming
out tomorrow in the States
called Clouds and Dirt.
It's the first video
that DRock made for me.
Let's hear it up for DRock.
(attendees applauding and cheering)
- [Attendees] DRock!
DRock!
- So the first video we ever
made was called Clouds and Dirt
and the reason we did that,
I think, it's important
because if you think about
it, it's no different
than the first issue of a comic book.
You're establishing the
origin story and I think
when I think about my
career and more importantly,
let's take me out of the equation,
when I look at the people that are winning
and when I say winning,
I think the biggest issue
we have right now is
how we define winning.
I think way too many
people are defining winning
based on how many followers somebody has,
how much money somebody has,
what things somebody has
and for me, I've realized as
I'm going through this process
it's unbelievable how much
to me the happiness factor
factors into winning.
Like what am I?
Are you happy?
Like by many standards, there's
so many different people
that maybe winning or losing
based on your singular judgment
but the reality is you have no idea
of what's really happening
within their mindset
and what's happening in their home.
You're looking at the outside facade
and I think as this
world continues to grow,
we've become incredibly adapt
at making us look a certain
way in our social media
versus what's really
happening in our head.
And that's something we've always done.
We've always bought
homes that were too big,
cars that were too much,
cloths that was too much
because we are unbelievably interested
in other people's opinions about us
versus our own opinions about ourselves.
And so when I think about why
the first film we ever made
was called Clouds and Dirt,
it's because it's my basic thesis in life
and definitely the reason
I'm successful in business
has a lot to do with clouds and dirt
because it's about the
macro and the micro.
It's about the strategy, the why.
To me, what really makes
me contemporary right now
and why this is a growing audience
and where my business is coming from
is coming from two reasons.
One, I'm in write about
what the world was gonna do
and I map strategies that
played out that worked.
My macro thesis was right.
It was very simple, it
wasn't super complicated.
10 years ago, I decided that this device
was way more important than
most people thought it was
and I decided whoever won on this device,
whoever controlled the home screen,
whether or not was email or text messaging
or social networks, whoever won that,
the people that won on top of that,
three layers, the internet, the platforms
on top of the Internet and then the people
that know how to use the
platforms on top of the internet
we're gonna be the winners.
The internet was gonna win, the platforms.
Facebook, YouTube, they were gonna win
and then the people that
knew how to execute next.
The vloggers, the
personalities and the startups
that knew how to make content at it.
It was a very simple thesis.
I executed against it but
that's only one part of it.
The other part of my macro
was not just my strategy and business,
it was that I figured myself
out at a very young age
that the game, the game
itself was what I loved.
And I'll be very frank, it
saddens me that so many people
in the audience's KPI
is figuring out a way
to maxing out money so that
they can then deploy that money
to buy things that think
will make them happy.
The reason that makes me
sad is I've just seen it
not work out time and time again.
People think it's the
money that makes them happy
or the thing they can buy with the money
and the reality is it
just doesn't play out.
And so for me the macro
was not only was I right
about where the attention of
every person was gonna end up
and then execute within it.
I knew that building it and eating shit.
Building and eating shit
was gonna make me happy.
I recognize that eating the dirt
is the thing that makes me most happy,
which means I'll never be upset.
Everybody's in a rush.
How many people here, raise
your hands, have talked to,
have heard me talk about patience?
Raise your hands.
Great, so I've had a
very interesting epiphany
to be very frank with you.
I didn't realize that I
love the patience so much
and push it so much because
I loved the process.
Of course, I love patience.
I never wanna stop.
As a matter of fact, on the way here,
I would say to somebody, I use the word,
I was like I'm just
foreplaying my business career
because I never want it to end.
I always wanna work.
I have no interest in ever retiring.
I don't want to buy a fucking island.
I don't want to sell VaynerMedia, right?
Even my business goals of buying the Jets.
The second I buy them,
it's gonna be fucking hard
to win a fucking Super Bowl, right?
I love the process.
I want the process.
You need to figure out
what your process is
because to be successful,
you have to understand
what's so amazing about the internet.
Why does every 15 to 20-year-old
wanna be an influencer?
Because they can.
Let me just say it really quickly.
Why does every 15 to 20-year-old
want to be an influencer?
Because they can.
You can make $50,000 a year.
You can make $100,000
a year, just being you
having brands subsidize your life
or selling t-shirts or whatever may be.
The reason most teenagers in the world,
in the world wanna be
a KOL or an influencer
is because it's practical.
Here's the problem with it.
Everybody can do it.
It's a supply and demand issue.
Everybody can start an Instagram
and YouTube account tomorrow
which by virtue means everybody can
which means you're
competing with everybody
which means you have to be good.
This is a very important point
because the reality is
actually work hard enough
to be good enough versus the next person,
you're gonna have to put in
so many hours in the game
and the only way to put in
the hours to differentiate
is to put in the hours.
We look for so many angles.
I am fascinated by how many people
are looking for the angle.
They make me feel like,
Gary, I hear all your stuff
but like whether they meet
me in a conference like this
in Q and A or on the street
or in a business meeting,
they're like yeah, yeah, yeah
but just give me the one thing.
My friends, there's no one thing.
They're like but the hack.
Like do you really think
there's some magical fucking
hashtag out there that's gonna blow up
your fucking account?
Like do you really think
that's how it works?
I'm just completely fascinated
by everybody's lack of
patience and lack of process
and so really my macro,
I'm starting and this is,
listen, I'm really excited
because I promise you this
and you'll see in my content
for the next five to seven years,
I will reference this trip and this speech
because I'm starting to realize.
(attendees applauding)
Calm down, calm down, you
still might fuck it up
so let's relax.
You still 35 minutes and
13 seconds, just relax.
But I realize that I'm starting
to put the pieces together
that the macro is not just having
the right business strategy.
Let me give you a macro.
Voice is gonna win.
Alexa and Google and Apple
are gonna build voice devices.
Everybody in this room
over the next 10 years
is gonna gravitate towards voice devices.
Apps are gonna be built on
top of the voice devices
and the next Spotify
and the next SoundCloud
and the next YouTube
and the next Facebook,
the next trillion dollar
companies will be voice apps.
It will be a huge industry.
Everybody here should go home
and read 10 hours a fucking
week about voice app,
voice devices, everybody
here should go by an Alexa,
you should absolutely have one.
Just work with your fucking
Siri, that fucking sucks today
but gets better.
Voice will win.
I'm giving you the macro strategy.
Put in the bank, DRock's
filming somewhere.
It's done, there's plenty of cameras here.
Voice will win, that's done.
It's gonna happen.
Now, what?
Everyday, I get emails from people like,
oh, Gary, this sucks.
Like I had the idea for
Uber before it happened.
Who gives a fuck about your idea?
Do you know why nobody
talks about copywriting
and patents anymore like
they used to 15 years ago?
'Cause they don't mean shit.
The game is about execution.
The reason most of you don't execute
is because other people's
opinions about you matter more
than your own about yourself.
No shit you can't work and
put out as much content.
You're worried about
other people's opinions.
You literally stop posting
more content on social media
'cause one random account named dutyface47
said that you were ugly or
stupid and that stopped you.
My friends, you have to
get your macro right.
You have to know where the world's going
or where you think it's going.
You have to know what you can do about it.
Cool, so now I just said
the voice is gonna win.
What just went through
all 2,000 people's heads?
Did you say and take a step back,
I'm gonna become an investor
and I'm gonna invest in the next Facebook
or Twitter on voice?
Is that your move?
Did you take a step back
and say, you know what?
I've been thinking about doing a podcast.
Let me make a voice app
along with that podcast
and try to win there?
Did you take a step back
and say you're gonna start
advertising on voice apps
when they first come out
to sell your t-shirts or your
course or your real estate?
What did you decide when you
heard voice was gonna win?
But most of all, you've got
to be in a good enough place
to execute and win and
you've got to understand
it's about pattern recognition.
For me, whether it was baseball
cards or lemonade stands
or the liquor store, my career
has been basically the same.
If I was standing here in 1996
when I launched winelibrary.com,
I would tell you that the
internet was gonna win.
For all the youngsters in here,
a lot of people thought
the internet was a fad.
That it wasn't gonna be a big thing.
Next, it was gonna be email,
then it was gonna be Google AdWords,
then it was gonna be YouTube,
then it was gonna be social media.
It's all been the same thing.
It will always be the same thing.
Before I was in the business world,
it was television, cable.
Before that, network television.
Before that, radio.
Before that, newspapers.
This is not very complicated.
This is very simple.
Communication is how
people make decisions.
You wanna sell something?
You need somebody's
attention then you tell them.
You tell them through words,
you tell them through audio,
you tell them through video.
My friends, this is fucking simple.
This is fucking simple as shit.
Don't get it confused.
This is simple as fuck.
The phone has won.
If you do not have content
on LinkedIn, Facebook,
Twitter, YouTube, you don't exist.
Do you understand?
You don't fucking exist
if you're not putting out
something today, somebody else is,
you're losing market share.
I don't give a fuck how
much money you're making
and how good you're doing.
You are not standing still.
Either you're moving forward
and you're moving backwards.
It's as simple as that.
So if you're not posting
five, seven, 15, 30 pieces
of content a day on these
platforms, you're going backwards
because tons of people are.
It's that simple.
The question I have is why
the fuck aren't you doing it?
How many people here have
been watching my content
for more than a year?
Raise your hand.
Thanks.
The problem is if you're a year-plus in
like half this room is
and you're not posting
20, 30 pieces of content a day
regardless of what your job is,
regardless of what's going on,
you're just hearing me,
you're not executing.
You can read about push-ups
but if you don't do them, nothing happens.
And so what's really important to me
is I'm mainly interested in legacy.
And my legacy is at the mercy of you.
See most people like that
you don't do anything.
You know why?
Because you keep giving them money.
Most people like that
you don't do anything
because you keep giving them money.
The reason you keep giving
them money for courses
and things of that nature
and books and events
is because it makes you feel
like you're doing something.
Paying for information
and doing nothing with it
is being a fucking sucker.
So, it's true.
And so for me, I'm trying to figure out
how the fuck to get you to do shit.
My concept of fucking pounding
it in your head for free
every day, seven days a
week on every platform,
in every format is working to some degree.
The problem is it's not working for most.
And so I sit here today
in this room with you
desperately trying to figure out why.
And every day that goes
by, the more and more
it's getting very clear
to me why you're not.
It's getting clearer to
me that you are valuing
somebody's opinion more than
you're valuing your own.
You actually are worried
about what your parents think.
You're worried about
what your siblings think,
your girlfriend thinks,
your buddies think,
the world thinks.
You have allowed outside voices
to be more powerful than your own
and it will always dominate
you for the rest of time
and I can give you
unlimited fucking tactics,
I can give you the fucking money
and you're gonna fucking lose.
So please, if you allow me,
if it took being in person together,
you have to figure out who's
voice is louder than yours
and figure out what they're up to.
Why are they giving you that advice?
A lot of times, they think
they're giving you advice that's good.
They think they're doing the right thing.
But my friends, this is a mental game.
This is a mental warfare,
this is absolutely that
because the reality is,
actually, you know what?
This is a fair question
and honestly, we're here
so please be honest.
By show of hands, how many people aren't,
are not in the professional
place they'd like to be?
Raise your hands.
Raise it high.
Don't lie.
High, high, stand up.
stand up if you're not
in a professional place
that you wanna be.
Do it, I'm gonna wait.
There's nothing
embarrassing, I'm standing.
So own it, don't be full of shit.
Don't try to act cool
because you're sitting
and it makes it look
like that you're good.
Stand if you are not in
the professional place
that you wanna be.
Cool?
Everybody who's standing,
I have something that you need to hear
and I need you to listen very carefully.
This right now, the last 10
years of the global economy
and how much money's in it and this,
because of the internet and the devices
has made the last two, three,
four years the easiest time
in the history of
business to be successful.
Right now, we are living dead smack,
right now, dead smack in the easiest time
in the last three to
400 years to make money
and be professionally happy.
If your fucking standing,
we need to figure this
the fuck out.
Because if you're not winning right now,
you're in deep fucking shit
when shit hits the fan.
So if you were standing, you
need to figure out why that is
and I promise you, it is
not because it's hard.
It's because you haven't
figured out the right macro.
Either your mindset of what's getting you,
you can sit down, thank you so much.
Either the mindset or what to
do, the lack of self-awareness
is enormous in the system
right now and so for me,
the way you figure shit out,
the way you figure yourself out
is you try shit.
You try shit.
I used to think it was super basic.
I would stand up here over the
last decade and say try shit.
And I just wouldn't
understand why people wouldn't
and it keeps getting me
back to the same place.
The judgment.
And look, I have a very
specific agenda in Asia
over the next decade.
It is to change the conversation
of the way kids are parented in Asia.
I have one agenda.
There is a global issue across the world
from the United States to Europe
Australia to South America
that over indexes in Asia
which is that parents
are fucking up.
And they're fucking up because they care
about what other parents
think about their kids.
They want you to be a
fucking lawyer and doctor
'cause that seems cool
to their old friends.
- [Attendee] Amen.
- It is amen.
Here's the problem.
You're fucking up too 'cause
you're taking their money
and you are acting like you're not.
And so we have a very
intriguing moment in time,
really intriguing and I'm
trying to really hack it
because here's the part that
I'm most passionate about.
I always say don't listen
to what I'm saying,
watch what I do.
I've been producing content for 10 years.
I was unbelievably quiet
in 2014-15, 2013, right?
Building VaynerMedia, I was quiet.
I wasn't putting out a lot of content.
There was a specific reason.
I wasn't passionate about
saying anything, right?
I did for 11 years of my career.
I wrote Crush It!, I came out,
I was like hey, this shit
is really, like this,
if you go read Crush It! right
now, it was written in 2008,
it's ridiculous how much that
played out in personal brand.
It's the whole book, that's
why I wrote Crushing It!
because I was like fuck,
it's still happening
and a lot of people are winning
and it's fun to be here.
I mean like one of the
most interesting things
about the Philippines is
how remarkably underpriced
the ads are on YouTube and
Facebook and Instagram.
How many of they're doing
incredible work here
yet, there's not as much
money coming into them
so you could take advantage of it.
Everything I believe in and
you hear me talking about
is a better deal in the
Philippines than it is in the US,
is a better deal in Southeast Asia.
There's a reason I wanna open an office
in Southeast Asia for VaynerMedia.
It's because, it's.
(attendees cheering)
Thank you.
It's because it's better here.
I love when people cry when
they're not in bigger markets.
They're like oh, we only
have 30 million people.
We only have 10 million people,
we only have four million people.
It's easier.
America's the big leagues.
There's a lot of people doing it there.
300 million gets spread out
against a lot of people.
There's more abundance in
Southeast Asia right now
for this execution than almost
any other part of the world.
And so to me, we have a remarkable time
and the reason I want to be
out here talking about this now
and I mean this, everything I believe in
is about to go away.
Let me explain why I'm
so passionate about this.
It's early and it's underpriced.
Think of it as real estate.
Beachfront property of places
that get hot are a good deal
when they first become available.
And over time, they get properly priced.
Over the next decade,
Facebook and Instagram ads
are gonna go from three,
four, five, six, $7 CPMs
to 20, 30, 40, $50 CPMs.
In the same time, people's
usage is going to change.
You're gonna start not
converting as well in the feed.
So right now, I can get in
front of all of you on Facebook
for six, seven and $8 to get
in front of a thousand of you
and a hundred of you are
gonna do something with it
and literally in 48 months,
it's gonna cost me $53
to get in front of a thousand
of you but only 20 of you
are gonna do something with it.
That is very basic math.
This is historic.
This is exactly what happened with Google.
Google ad, how many
people here we're doing
Google AdWords marketing
in 2002, three, four?
Raise your hand.
Remember, for the six of us
that just raised their hands,
all of us, we fucked up.
We should have spent more money, right?
Every time there's a deal,
you regret not buying a lot of it.
Think about every good business
thing you've ever done,
if I take you in a time machine
and tell you what would you do,
you would bought more,
you would have done more.
That's exactly what's happening right now
with Facebook and Instagram
and it's happening right
in front of your face
and so I am desperate to talk about it
because it's right there
and it's going away quick.
And let me tell you
why it's gonna go away.
Because BMW and Coca-Cola
and Mercedes-Benz
are spending their money
on dumb shit right now.
They're buying television commercials,
they're buying billboards,
they're buying print ads,
they're buying banner ads on websites.
What the fuck?
I don't even owned a computer
in four fucking years.
Like banner ads on websites
in a mobile only world,
when they realize that and
their money goes into Facebook
and Instagram for real,
not the bullshit money
they're putting it now,
all these prices will go up.
So I implore you, I implore
you to take a step back
and understand the moment in
time that we have right now.
And ask yourselves why,
why are you not doing
more of this single thing?
And the interesting
thing is I'm most worried
about both the clouds and the dirt.
The people that are most
winning in this room,
who's having the best year
of their professional career?
Raise your hand.
Good.
You scare me even more than the people
that were fucking standing.
The reason you're not doing
all of this as hard as you can
is 'cause you are having the best year
and whatever is doing that
is what you're focused on,
not this ridiculously underpricing.
Every day, I sit with
companies that say to me,
Gary I get all this but
we're up 9% doing television.
Our business is up 9%.
And I look at them and I say,
Rick, what's wrong with 35%?
There are two things that
are always scary to me.
Having way too little
and having way too much.
And so for me, we are
clearly in a very unique time
if you are a historian about
the business world and society
and this room, the fact that
you're even in it on a Sunday
means that you already
have theoretical advantage
versus the masses to be
opened to execute within this.
My problem is I just think
90% of you wanna be here
to feel good about doing it
versus actually doing it.
And I'm trying to figure
out how to unwind that
and figure out why.
Why in the world do so many
people who could easily make
a couple hundred thousand
dollars a year selling t-shirts
on Facebook by just running Facebook ads
think it's smarter to buy
unlimited amounts of Bitcoin.
I'll tell you why.
People like lottery tickets.
People bought cryptocurrency at scale
because they thought it was
gonna change their lives, right?
Wasn't Bitcoin supposed to
be $100,000 a coin today?
So I'm trying to understand
why that was seductive.
I get how it works, I understand.
That makes sense to me in desperate times.
The problem is we're living
in times of abundance.
This is fucking ridiculous abundance.
People aren't willing to eat shit.
People aren't willing to
put in the grind work.
It's sitting right there
and I'm desperately
trying to figure out
why you're not doing it.
Let me give you a couple tactics,
a couple things to talk about.
Super interesting thing to look at,
how many people are into B2B business.
Raise your hands.
B2B, raise it high.
I'm just trying to get a sense
so I can give you some stuff.
Okay, real quick for the B2B people,
it is fascinating how
much LinkedIn has exploded
in being a content play like Facebook
over the last three years.
I've been doing quite well with it
but in the last six months,
it's gotten remarkable.
The organic reach is through the roof
and if you are in B2B here
and you are not posting
one to three blogs a day,
you can do written blogs, I embed videos
and then transcribe them.
It's remarkable, the ads
are not as good as Facebook
because there's a floor but
if you are a personality
that cares about business
or you're in the B2B space
and I would actually argue
even if you don't think
your brand or your personality
belongs in LinkedIn,
if you would interpret it to
business people are watching it
and come from that angle and respect
the context of the room,
I believe that LinkedIn right now
is a remarkable white space in marketing
and I highly recommend.
The things that I always
dream of when I aspire
to bring value to a conference is,
and I've seen a lot of your
faces when I position that,
a lot of people like, huh?
And then she was like, yay.
So she's clearly killing
it on fucking LinkedIn.
My ambition is that you go
back and this puts a seed
in your head and you go and
read for three to six hours
but most of all, you go
and do for six months.
Biggest reason so many people are failing
in today's new environment
is it takes work.
You don't just run a
Facebook ad and it works.
You might suck at running Facebook ads.
People are practitioners.
And so they're not good at the craft.
I've I have spent tens,
hundreds of thousands of dollars
on Facebook that did not achieve
the goal that I had for it.
And so, there are people
in this room who've run
a thousand dollars worth of
Facebook ads, it didn't work
and you've decided Facebook
marketing doesn't work.
Number two.
Twitter is going through
an interesting time
and a lot of people think
it has to do with Trump
and this kind of stuff and that's fine.
It's not that.
What's happening is Jack
and the original team
came back 18 months ago and
it's just little tweaks,
little tweak here, a little week there
but if you are just starting
out no matter what you're doing
or if you're in a small base,
the fact that you can go
to Twitter and search words
and jump into the conversation
and go from not being known at all
to creating contexts and relationships
with people in the industry
or customers is remarkable.
The problem is nobody wants to do it
because it's not scalable.
But when you're at zero and
you're trying to establish
your brand or business,
I think it's remarkable
to go into Twitter for two hours a day
and reply to people talking
about football or scarfs
or courses or haircuts
or jam or camera lenses
or whatever the fuck you care about.
To me, I don't understand
why somebody's not willing
to put in the hours when they're asking
for the audacity of changing their lives
and living it on their terms.
Running a business or
making money on your terms
that's sustainable and is a
good life is extremely rare.
So of course, it's gonna be
super hard and Twitter search
is super hard because
it takes a lot of time
but it's two things that are
super interesting for me.
It's super works and it's super free.
It's free.
The amount of people that tell me,
Gary always talking about free,
why should I speak for free?
Why should I do this for free?
And I always ask them like,
people always push me,
Gary, you have to know what you're worth.
You can't do it for free.
You have to know your worth.
And I'm like but the market's telling you
that you're worth zero.
Right?
Like people like, you're only emailing me
because you haven't sold anything
but you don't wanna do it for free.
The market has told you you're zero.
There's so many macro
things fucked up right now,
I can't believe it as I
get older and uncover them.
Not wanting to work for free
means you have a big fucking
ego without achieving anything.
There's so much audacity,
there's an unbelievable lack of humility.
And so to me this is a
very interesting time
and I'm gonna say it again
because I like to recall it
so that you understand
why my head is here.
This era and by the way,
how many people here consume my content?
Raise your hand.
Thank you.
You know where I sit on this.
It's only four or five things.
For the people that don't,
let me take a step back
because I didn't see
as many hands as I need
and I wanna make sure I bring you value.
Number one, you have to figure out
how you communicate to the world.
Are you video?
Are you audio?
Are you written word?
Everybody here, if you
do not produce content
for the internet, you might
as well get up and leave
because that means you
fucking are finished.
This is no longer 2007.
You can't debate this anymore.
If you do not produce
content for the internet,
you do not exist.
So if you believe that
were finally accepted it,
how do you communicate?
How do you create content to the internet?
Is it written word?
Is it audio?
Is it video?
How many of you here listen to podcasts?
Any of them, raise your hand.
Raise it high.
I want everybody in the
front to look around.
Raise it high, keep it high.
This is a remarkable amount of hands.
Thank you so much.
If I ask this question three years ago,
80% of the hands that
are up would be down.
For me, podcasting is remarkable.
I genuinely think more
than half of this room
should have a podcast.
It takes no engineers.
There's an app called Anchor,
I'm not associated with it at all
but some of you see me throw it,
I just think it's a good thing.
It's fucking free.
You record it on your phone
as if you're on the phone,
you don't need any
infrastructure, no sound engineer,
you press three buttons and you
are in the podcast business.
Written word, here's a
look dirty little secret
and I'm being a little more
tactical which makes me happy
so take advantage of it because it's rare.
Long-form copy on Facebook
and Instagram work.
Everybody spends so much
time great about the picture
and they fucking mail in the words.
Everybody here on
Instagram is trying to grow
because it's completely won, right?
And everybody's fuckin' triple filter.
I mean there's people
literally spend like 12 minutes
filtering their fucking photo.
And then if you're a
personal brand and a human,
I mean I don't know if you guys know this.
The only thing that I'm sure
that Instagram taught me
is somehow, every fucking
person is attractive.
Every single person is spending
so much time on the photo
and don't forget, a lot of you
are trying to position
yourself as a business person.
So please understand that
one of the huge white spaces
on Facebook and Instagram
is writing a ton of shit.
It works.
Take that with you.
As matter of fact, back to LinkedIn,
I don't know if you felt this.
What's been really
interesting about LinkedIn
and it goes against
kind of my natural state
just the written stuff
and I mean like literally
and you see what I do on Instagram
with the pictures and stuff like that,
that works on Instagram.
On LinkedIn, if I put that
same picture with a quote
versus just writing the copy,
the copy will destroy it on LinkedIn.
So these are the nuances and the tactics
that so many people ask before.
The reason I don't get excited about them
is they're very easy to see.
I keep telling you, just
watch what I'm doing.
If you went to my LinkedIn and see
that there's a bunch
of written copy there,
I do nothing for my health.
I do nothing for kicks and giggles.
This is all being fucking thought about.
I don't do a podcast seven days a week
because I think it's funny.
I do it 'cause it works.
I do it 'cause audio is important.
My friends, I put out
a couple of months ago,
maybe a year ago, a strategy called
the $1.80 Strategy on Instagram.
What it was was go to 90
people leave your two cents
on their comments.
I believe in it more, not less.
How many people here, is anybody
here verified on Instagram?
Anybody?
Okay, Instagram, leaving
comments in communities
versus you go to Instagram,
you search the hashtag,
you search words that are
associated to your business,
you know your business
and you go to 80, 90
different accounts that are
posting and you leave comments
and you don't leave comments
like yo or thumbs up.
You look what they're
posting, you read it,
you take a minute, you think
and you write something of value.
The biggest problem right now
is everyone's in short term and numbers.
Let me get to 150 accounts.
I'd much rather you get to
19 and read it carefully
'cause you'll convert 12 out of 19
versus one out of 150.
Depth, everybody's in width.
Numbers, numbers, numbers.
You know why most people
don't grow on social networks
over the last decade?
They care more what the
audience is doing for them
than what they're doing for the audience.
When you post on Instagram,
you're looking for them to give you likes.
The amount of people that tell
me that they're struggling,
I look at it and they have
not replied to one person
in the comment section of their posts.
You're trying to build a community,
yet you are not part of it.
Audacity, taking things for granted.
Only looking at it for
what's in it for you.
Who made you so entitled that you think
you should be an influencer or
a millionaire or successful?
We have way too much entitlement,
way too much laziness,
way too much audacity in the system
and I am passionate to get rid of it.
Not because I think that I'm
cool and I'm scolding you.
I'll be very frank with you, Manila.
I don't give a fuck if you
do anything I talked about.
I can't, I can't go to
your house and make you.
But I will not change my tune.
My favorite thing that's
happening right now
in my comments on YouTube and Instagram
and let be very clear here
if you wanna learn what I do,
if you want, I read all of them.
I read all my comments
because that's how I know
what to do next.
The amount of people
that just post and leave,
no engagement, no reading comments
is a clear indication to
why so few people win.
Post and leave.
Imagine hosting a dinner in your home
and putting down the plate
and leaving the fucking house.
That is what 98% of you
are doing on Instagram.
The place you wanna win.
And you think following and unfollowing
or algorithm and scripts
where all this dumb fucking
hackers, you fucking hackers.
I literally just said follow and unfollow
and like 12 you just looked
at the person next to you
and smile and said, fuck, that's us.
I just don't understand
how you don't understand how life works.
Short-term behavior with
no good intent behind it
that is completely predicated
on what's in it for you
has never worked for anybody
in the history of time.
Shortcuts, impatience.
And that's what got me all
the way back to the last part
which is okay, this is what
I've been watching for a decade.
This has been my passion and
frustration for a decade.
I'm finally starting to understand why.
This is way deeper, this
is 100% entitlement.
This is 100% what's been going on
for the last 20 to 40
years with parenting.
This is a 100% that you
glamorize the products.
I ask myself, why don't I give
a fuck about Louis Vuitton
or Supreme or fucking these watch.
Why don't I give a fuck?
Because I realize subconsciously,
every time I see somebody
completely being about that,
I know that they're not happy.
They're leveraging it to disguise.
Everybody's in the makeup business.
Everybody's full of fucking shit.
And that sucks because I
don't know if you heard,
it's really hard to be a human being
and since you will never
do anything as remarkable
as having a life in itself,
I just hate that you're pissing it away
based on trying to keep
up with the Joneses.
Like so many of you are depressed
because when you go on
your Instagram account,
your friends on vacation in Bali
or like has a bottle of champagne
or like don't you understand
that everybody's just a
PR agent of themselves
on social media?
Like how many more times
do you need to see families
posting unbelievable
happy pictures on Facebook
for months and months and years and years
and then finally there's a post that says,
me and Karen have decided to split.
Are you watching?
The single greatest abundance opportunity
in the history of mankind
is happening directly in your face.
It's called the internet.
It's only about 25 years old,
it's happening while you're alive.
Not only were you lucky at 400
trillion to one to be alive,
you weren't born during the
Black Plague or World War II
or all the other shit that
other people were born with.
No, you were born during 50
years of global prosperity
and so much money in the system,
it doesn't know where to put itself.
That's you.
So if you're actually
unhappy during right now,
you're actually the
worst humans of all time.
I'm being serious and
I'm not trying to razz
or hurt feelings.
I hope you understand, I
know a lot of you know me.
I have no interest in that.
I'm just trying to ask you
to fucking look at life
from a different angle.
You know, many people
literally go into debt
and then not like their
life for the next 20 years
because they needed to buy
a house that has six rooms
more than they need
because they needed to make
pretend they're more
successful than they are.
We have to eradicate that.
Guys, we have to eradicate
keeping up with the Joneses.
I'm gonna personally kill the Joneses.
The Joneses are fuckin' cancer.
Like guys, everybody else sucks too.
Please stop living your life
on somebody else's terms.
Because I give you and
millions of other people
give you very basic information
every day that works.
Run Facebook ads, you'll make money.
The information is basic is fuck.
What's not basic is this.
This is the fucked up thing.
This is the game, this is
the game, this is the game.
And the sad truth is most
people are losing this game.
You guys spend more time
upgrading your phone
than you upgrade your mind.
Please, and upgrading your mind
isn't getting more educated,
upgrading your mind is
understanding why you do things
for whom and how.
We need to take a massive
collective step back,
massive step back and say what
the fuck are we doing here?
What are you scared of?
Why are you not doing that?
Who's scaring you?
Who is this thing?
The reality is unfortunately
the thing that scares you
are usually the people closest to you.
The ones that love you.
Be very smart about who gives you advice
and how happy they are.
I'm happy as fuck.
But if you listen to the last hour,
it feels kind of razzy and negative.
Meanwhile, a lot of other
people say they love you
and this and that.
But they're miserable as shit.
Do not judge a book by its cover.
Get more thoughtful
because here's the part
that bothers me the most.
If you don't figure your
shit out now and execute,
you're gonna be double
depressed in seven years
when the opportunities are nowhere close
to as good as they are now.
Manila, this our fucking time.
Please, please figure it out
and get your shit into motion.
You have one life to live,
do something about it.
Thank you.
(attendees applauding and cheering)
- [Host] Thank you so much.
Mr. Gary Vaynerchuk!
- Thank you.
Q and A?
- [Host] Please stay because
ladies and gentlemen,
45 minutes is not enough with Gary Vee.
True or true?
- [Attendees] True!
- Please, everyone sit down,
we still have something for you.
In the next few minutes,
we are opening the floor
to something very special, all right?
This was supposed to be a
private session with Gary Vee
but the organizers and Gary
decided to be so generous,
they are going to open the
Q and A for everyone too.
Yes, very good, for everyone to listen
but the people who will
get to ask questions
are the people in front.
VIP and solitaire, you
are going to be asking
your very well-thought-out question.
- Or shitty.
- Or shitty, okay, we'll take
shitty questions any time.
We have to mike stations,
one on this side and the
other one on this side.
If you have a smart question,
just queue for the Q and A.
And please take note,
no long life stories.
Like Gary, when I was a little boy.
No, please, go straight to the question
and please you don't have
to say Gary, we love you
so I could follow you, no.
We already know that.
So go straight to the question
so that more people can ask.
Good?
Thank you.
Gary.
- Yep, great, my friend, okay?
- [Attendee] Me first, you first?
- [Attendee] You first.
- All right.
Okay, first question.
I have a couple.
- [Gary] Sure.
- All right, why haven't you
been in a Shark Tank yet?
- [Gary] 'Cause I said no.
- Oh, they offered it to you?
- [Gary] They sure did.
- Oh, that's awesome.
Why?
Why did you say no?
- Because I tend not to like be to,
when I think about my brand,
I like doing things where
I'll get the credit,
not the platform.
- [Attendee] I see.
- Right?
So if I was to be Shark Tank now
and Shark Tank's an incredible show.
I'm a fan, I love that
young kids watch it.
I think it's positive.
I'm a big fan of Shark Tank.
The reason I decided not
to do it is at this point,
it's a mature brand, right?
And I'm going into somebody
else's house and I can't,
like it's not going anywhere higher.
It's on the decline.
So I think of Shark Tank
the way I think about
American Idol, right?
What I'm spending my time
on and why I switched
from CAA to William Morris recently
is while Shark Tank's
doing what it's doing,
and it and I think it's American Idol,
I'm trying to develop something
that could become like The Voice.
Right, like I wanna make the business show
we're on the face of
that disrupts Shark Tank,
not be season 11 Shark Tank Gary Vee.
- That's right, couple
more questions, okay?
Yeah, all right, did your
guessing on Joe Rogan's podcast
when you were there the first time,
did it force you to get into shape?
- No, Rogan's?
- [Attendee] Yeah, Rogan's.
- I don't know if it was a bad angle
but I was already in shape
when I went on that show.
No, I got into shape
because it's a good idea.
Literally, what's really interesting
is everything I just
talked about for 45 minutes
is the business and mental version
of why I figured out getting into shape.
I was 38 years old and I was
not in good physical shape
and I knew it was a
good idea to live longer
to be in better shape
but I couldn't fucking
figure out the angle
and literally on a plane,
it hit me that I'm not good
when I'm accountable to myself.
I'm great when I'm accountable to others.
I like doing for others,
that's my selfish move.
I'm a good boss, I'm a good leader,
I'm good with my community so I realized,
if I hired somebody full-time
and that became the team,
I wouldn't wanna let him down
and I literally figured out my health
by doing something rogue,
and so no, Rogan didn't
inspire me to get in shape.
- All right, you predicted
the fall of Toys R Us.
- [Gary] Yes.
- How the fuck did you do that?
- Because it's the same reason that I know
that everything I just
talked about is right
for 80% of this audience.
It's just in the math.
They were not doing anything right, right?
They were not winning
online, they were not,
they they would spend
more money on doing flyers
than on social media and I
knew that the toy business
was moving into a place
of direct-to-consumer.
If you have a child globally,
you know that they live on YouTube Kids
and if you look at why Slime or Shopkins
or any of these trends happen
that they happen at YouTube Kids
and then they go direct to consumer.
Between people selling
directly on Instagram,
Walmart and Costco and Amazon,
there was no place for Toys R Us.
- Sure, all right, I'm gonna ask about,
sorry, last question, I'm
gonna ask about two people.
One is a foreign celebrity,
one is a local celebrity.
You know both of them.
What was the interaction like
with the greatest Instagrammer
for all time, The Rock?
- That was super fun because
The Rock is so willing
to still live in the dirt
even though he's floating
in the clouds at all times.
When you meet people,
you're always curious
how are they, right?
Are they similar this
side, the other thing?
I think The Rock is ambitious
as fuck and that excites me.
- What was the interaction
like with Will Dasovich?
- So I loved will because
will is super humbling for me
because he was so inspired by
the content that I brought up
and obviously, he had a
very unique life story
of like adversity that led
him to where he is today.
The utter kindness and
good inside of Will's body
is ridiculously inspiring and
if you don't know who he is,
you should really pay attention.
- All right, one last.
Sorry, sorry, I promise to give it around.
One last, one last, okay.
Your most viral post ever.
This is for me, the one
that really hit me the most
is not giving a fuck about
what other people think.
- [Gary] Yes.
- Could you say it again?
No, because I think it
moved a lot of people and--
- It was the whole fucking
keynote I just gave, right?
And to your point, it is the answer.
Literally, literally, if
you are unhappy in this room
or not as happy as you
could be, it is 90% likely
that you're upset with your mom or dad.
When I say don't give a fuck
about what people think,
it's easy for you to not give
a fuck about what he thinks.
I'm talking about the people--
- [Attendees] Loved ones.
- Yes, I'm talking about
the people closest to you.
You've got problem with
I see the life right now
where I don't give a fuck
about what my mom, my dad and my wife say.
I respect them tremendously,
I care tremendously
but at its core, it's
gotten very quiet for me
which is why I'm so happy.
- Thanks so much for coming to Manila.
- [Gary] You got it.
- Thank you so much.
- [Attendee] Hey, Gary.
- Hey, brother.
- [Attendee] Waited a year
to ask you this question.
- Thank you.
- I want to fast forward
300 years from now.
- [Gary] Okay.
- And how the world
will remember you then.
- [Gary] Yes.
- so I believe that
you won't be remembered
as speaker, author, entrepreneur.
I believe you'll be remembered
as a 21st century philosopher.
- [Gary] Yes.
- And I just want to,
my question is of all your philosophies,
what do you think will be the philosophy
that will be still talked
about 300 years from now?
(attendees applauding)
- Thank you.
Probably, especially how I think
the next hundred years work out
that kindness and gratitude and good
is always just a little bit
stronger than fear and hate
and negativity.
(attendees applauding)
- Personally, I think, your
philosophy on parenting
is something that's gonna hugely impact
your generation of followers.
Especially here in the Philippines.
- Thank you, I think and it's interesting
'cause it's bubbling up and
I've been louder about it.
I agree with you that if
I had a bet and obviously,
I know what's going on
in my head and my actions
in the same way that don't give a fuck
or there was a video I made
about for 40 to 60 year olds
which is like, how many
people here are over 40?
Raise your hands.
Such an interesting crowd for me.
We just have so much more time, right?
We just have so much more time.
This parenting conversation
is probably gonna change
the course of my life
'cause it's deep as fuck.
It's true as fuck and nobody
wants to talk about it.
Nobody wants to talk about it.
And no question now
that I'm getting closer
to talk about it, I promise you,
I'm not in Asia for kicks and giggles.
It needs to be talked about
in this region yesterday.
- Amen, thank you.
(attendees applauding)
- [Attendee] How are you doing, Gary?
- Good brother.
- I'm gonna go into the semantics of how,
if you we're a--
- You don't wanna talk
about 300 years from now?
- No, no, no, we're here now.
If you are a
direct-to-consumer beauty brand
and you were launching in six months,
what would be three
strategies you'd focus on?
- Are you building on top of Shopify?
- [Attendee] Yes.
- That's good.
I would spend all my time
and energy on Facebook
and Instagram.
Dude, it's so black and white.
If you were to start a
direct-to-consumer business
in any category and you
just stay disciplined
in being a practitioner
on Facebook and Instagram,
you will get it to $5 million
revenue in 20 seconds,
a year, 18 months if you're average.
It's literally that true.
It's that underpriced.
It's early Google.
To me, that's number one.
- And when that cost of
advertising goes 10x?
- You'll deal with it then.
- Where do you shift your focus to?
- Who the fuck knows?
Right?
And it's interesting, right?
Because you said hey I
wanna talk about now,
cool, so let's not talk
about 300 years from now,
let's not even talk
about 31 months from now.
If you're launching shortly,
you've got minimum of two to three years,
it's gonna take too much money,
too fast to actually fuck with the pricing
so it's not gonna happen.
- Where do you see Amazon
sitting within that strategy?
- I think you should be on Amazon as well
and not fear that it
cannibalizes your margin.
You should use it as a
brand building exercise
and you should Amazon
optimized and be very careful
to work Amazon and Shopify carefully.
I always think fuck Amazon
before it fucks you, right?
So build brand in Amazon
which means you'll do sales
but when you're engaging
with those customers
and the first party data
start creating rationale
for them to not, and that's hard
because Amazon's convenient as fuck.
But certain packs, certain experiences
always find reasons to
buy on you versus there
but I would be on Amazon
because Amazon's grossly
underpriced as well.
Got it?
It's the path of the two.
Everyone thinks it's one or the other.
I think it's both.
- [Attendee] Sure.
- Yeah.
- Thank you.
- Influencers, man,
influencers are fucking crazy underpriced.
It's not scalable because you
have to DM them all day long
but like attractive people on
Instagram is fucking money.
- And so what layer of influencers
do you think are still affordable?
- All of them.
- [Attendee] All of them?
- I see people who are macro influencers
who have 13 million followers
who want 50,000 a post
but it's worth 100,000 and
I see micro influencers
who have 4,000 followers
who want $100 a posts
that are worth 400 bucks
and they're both good.
- So you think it's still worth
spending money on influencers?
- A hundred thousand percent.
Especially in the beauty supply space.
- [Attendee] Okay, thank you.
- Yeah, you got it.
(attendees applauding)
- [Shawn] Hey, Gary.
- How are you?
- Good, I'm Shawn, I'm from Australia.
Flew away to see this.
- [Gary] Thank you.
- First question, are
you coming to Australia?
- Yeah, I'm actually coming
with the week of October 17th
and I'm gonna be speaking in four cities.
And so you probably
didn't have to come here.
(attendees laughing)
- Right, I'll go to that one too.
- [Gary] Awesome.
- Same question.
So I own a few gyms in Australia.
So most of my content is on Instagram.
I wanna sort of ask you
what your differences
between obviously the Story and the IGTV
and posting just on your timeline.
So if you're gonna post
something you on your Story,
you're gonna do it on your
timeline too and on IGTV?
- I would think about
it smarter than that.
I would have pillars for,
you know, if you look at me, right?
Look what I'm doing versus what I say.
If you look what I'm doing with Stories,
in Stories, I'm doing a
lot of call to actions,
a lot of swipe ups then
I'm doing a lot of things
that are valuable for people, right?
That's where I'm doing screensavers
and different things of that nature.
IG, the main platform I'm
putting out consistent content
of the kind of, what I
would call my main stuff
but it's pure content.
There is no right hooks in there.
It's all content for the masses
and IGTV, we're just starting with
but we're producing original
content just for it.
So I would have a different
strategy for all three layers
because if it becomes redundant,
people gonna start realizing
that and tuning out
for two out of the three
which is giving away
some of the tools that you could be using.
- And now, most of my content
is also fitness-based.
But I wanna get a lot more
personal with with my crowd
so I wanna introduce my family and--
- So that's where maybe
you do a vlog on IGTV
while on the Stories and
main, you see where I'm going?
- [Shawn] Yeah, yeah.
- You should also be on YouTube,
as a gym, you should be
on YouTube and as a gym,
you should probably start a podcast.
- [Shawn] I'm going.
- Great.
- Okay.
- Awesome.
- Good, thank you,
- You got it.
Hi.
- [Clara] Hi, good afternoon.
- Good afternoon.
- All right, I'm Clara.
- [Gary] Clara.
- It okay to be spiritual
or philosophical?
- Yes, of course.
- All right.
What's that one thing in life
that you're most certain of?
- Most--
- [Clara] More certain of.
- That doing the right thing
is always the right thing.
100%.
I really believe in that.
Because doing the right
thing usually means
you have to give up
something in the short term
and that is so difficult for many.
They don't wanna give up
the money in the short term.
They don't like feeling,
you know many people here lose in life
because they hate the
feeling of somebody else
getting something over on them?
They're incapable of
being the bigger person.
Doing the right thing is
always the right thing.
- Yes, and last question.
What makes a thought leader
a mover or a shaker for you?
- Somebody who's talking the truth.
The biggest reason I
disrespect 95% of the people
that most people respect is because I know
they're not telling the truth.
- Yes, right.
Thank you.
(attendees applauding)
- [Attendee] Hi, Gary.
- How are you?
- I'm good, thank you.
How are you?
- Great.
So my question,
it's so psyched that you're here.
Thank you for coming to Manila.
- I'm so happy to be here.
- My question is if you would
live up to 100 year old.
- [Gary] Which I plan on.
- Which you plan on.
- By the way, that's very serious.
Back to us 40-year-olds,
like just very basic.
I'm not deep in the medical
space but I've been flirting
'cause as you get older,
you start giving a shit.
It's a layup if you're under 55
that you're gonna live to 105, 110.
And like pretty healthy
and happy to about 95.
So I'm planning on living
to 100, so go ahead.
- What advice--
- And by the way, you're
probably gonna live to 125.
- Oh, thank you.
I'm not planning to, actually.
- [Gary] Okay, weird.
- What advice would you give
to a 100-year-old Gary Vee and vice versa?
What advice with a 100-year-old Gary Vee
give to the present Gary Vee?
- So the biggest,
the reason I think I'm so happy
and so much is happening with me right now
is because the way I'm wired,
this is my perfect time.
I'm an optimist.
So when you're optimistic,
it's really just easy.
Like I genuinely believe
everything is gonna be okay
and is good and I find the good.
A lot of that has to do
with having more time.
The biggest fear I have
is that when I get into
my 80s, 90s, a hundred,
then I'll start becoming
resentful or not as happy
because I give so much as I
start running out of time,
I could potentially regret on not taking
whatever maybe at that point
I don't feel like I got enough of.
So if I'm giving right now the advice
to the 100-year-old Gary, it
would be less of an advice,
it would be me saying,
hey 100-year-old, Gary
like don't be pissed at me
but I'm doing the best that I can, right?
And it's a very important point.
I genuinely think that
people are always trying
to figure what I'm up to and the punchline
is I'll be less good when I get older
when time is running out.
I mean that.
I can see it, I can be
self-aware, I see it.
I hope not.
Sometimes why I wish for
a quick sudden death in 88
so I have to go through that period
because I know that's my vulnerability.
As far as the 100-year-old
giving me advice,
I'd like to think that
he'd be looking down
and saying just keep doing
exactly what you're doing.
- Nice, thank you so much.
- [Gary] You got it.
- [Attendee] Hi, Gary.
- How are you?
- Yeah, I have three questions, actually.
- [Gary] Go ahead.
- Short questions.
- First question is do you have any plan
of selling your sneaker's
here in the Philippines?
- Do I have any plans on selling what?
- [Attendee] Your sneakers.
- Here in the Philippines?
- [Attendee] Yes.
(attendees applauding)
- Thank you.
I don't think this one.
So the 003, the first
two were just in the US.
The 003 is far more global.
There is some eight
ways to get it in Asia.
It is available in Australia.
Like Monday, I find
out exactly where it is
but for the 004, we think
we're gonna be able to cover
the whole world and that'll
will be in November.
- Oh, yeah, that's
perfect, that's perfect.
Okay, second question is,
let's see.
- [Gary] What are you,
making it up on the spot?
- No, actually, I follow up--
- You know my favorite part is?
You literally said you had three questions
and you don't even have fucking two.
- No, I'm thinking about how to say it.
- [Gary] Okay, go ahead.
- Okay, second question is
to everyone on the medical
and dental field.
- [Gary] Okay.
- Is there any way to like
promote on Facebook or Instagram
without scaring off
the customers because--
- [Gary] I think so.
- In our Filipino culture.
- [Gary] I get it.
- If you're a parent
and you have rowdy kids,
you usually tell them,
if you don't shut up,
I'm gonna bring you to the
dentist or something like that.
- I fucking hate the dentist.
Yeah, so I get it.
- [Attendee] I'm a dentist.
- I get it.
(attendees applauding and laughing)
I get it.
I figured.
Absolutely.
It's really interesting.
I actually think in
Crushing It!, 'cause I,
that we actually feature
a dentist in the book.
If I recall proper, I think
there's a huge way to do it
and the beauty of Facebook
ads is you can run them
against different demos
and understand them.
I think you need to put
out informational content
but I think there's an absolute way.
I don't think you're gonna convince kids
who are scared of the dentist to go
but I definitely think
that you can win 35 to 65
with information.
- Okay, Gary, thank you.
- [Gary] You're welcome.
- Last question is, sorry.
I know you're an immigrant,
I'm also an immigrant.
There used to be a time in the Philippines
where there are a lot of people
coming to the Philippines
for greener pastures but now,
there's like millions of
Filipinos leaving the Philippines
looking for greener pastures
and of course, to make money,
to make ends meet.
But now, there's so much like
so many job opportunities
in the e-commerce.
YouTube, Facebook.
Is there any way to
like tell them to like,
hey, you can actually come
back to the Philippines
because there's so many things,
you can actually earn here
and be with your family.
- [Gary] Why?
Why?
- Because actually, there's
so many Filipinos going abroad
leaving their families behind.
- I see, to bring money.
Look, I think sure, you're more
than welcome to make videos
on the side while being a dentist
educating people about
this amazing opportunity
and running ads on Facebook in that.
The answer is yes, there's
opportunity to do it.
The question becomes who wants to do it?
- [Attendee] Yeah.
- Do you know what I mean?
Like for me, for some reason,
nobody's wanted to talk about
the truth about parenting
so I was like fuck it, I'll do it.
So the answer is of course
there's opportunity.
The question is who's gonna do it and why.
- My pleasure, thank you very much.
- [Gary] You got it.
Hi.
- [Attendee] Hi, Gary.
- How are you?
- I'm good, thank you.
So you've built this incredibly
massive online empire.
- [Gary] Yes.
- Do you have a system for
consistently generating
viral content?
- No, because viral content by nature
is viral and uncontrollable.
I have a system to
produce consistent content
with the hope of it being viral.
Do you know how many
people sit around all day
trying to figure out how
to make something viral?
- [Attendee] Yeah.
- That's against the definition of viral.
Make content, make good content
and then have your moments in time.
Do you know what I mean?
- [Attendee] Yeah.
- And let me tell you one
thing about everybody here
who's still waiting for their
first piece of viral content.
It's not as exciting as you think it is.
It'll do great, you'll
build up bigger lists,
more things will happen
and then two days later,
you'll just be bleep,
it just a little higher.
It's not this great
nirvana that people think.
Everybody's looking for this quick thing
and that's why people love viral.
There's this dream that you're gonna make
some sort of Facebook
post or YouTube video
or Instagram post and it's
gonna change your life.
There's a reason lotto tickets work.
People are looking for the quick fix.
And it happens once every
billion, half a million,
trillion times and then
everybody looks at that
versus looking at the truth.
Hippos and sharks.
Do you know what that means?
- No.
- Let me tell you.
Everybody's scared of sharks,
meanwhile, hippos kill way
more people than sharks.
Right?
- Right.
- Terrorism.
People super scared of terrorism.
Meanwhile, texting and
driving will kill more people
in the world this week
than terrorism will.
Viral.
Everybody wants viral.
But what actually works
is consistent content.
(attendees applauding)
- Thank you, Gary.
- You're welcome.
- [Attendee] Hey, man.
- Hey, man.
- So I actually have just
two questions for you.
- [Gary] Go ahead.
- And I kind of want to
relate to the Filipinos.
I was really glad that you pointed out
that thing we had with our parents.
Well, most of the parents actually.
- [Gary] Yeah, it's a
general statement but yes.
- Yeah, and I think there's another thing,
there's another huge factor
that actually stops us
here in the Philippines
from actually thinking or
like getting to your mindset
which is basically the way we rely
on the institutions here for education.
- Yes, couldn't agree more.
Entitlement.
- Yeah, entitlement
and so I wanted to ask,
what do you think education is?
What do you think education would be,
at least at the most part of
the world in maybe 10 years
once they start realizing the
thing we have for education.
- Yes, so education
super interesting to me
because education is imperative.
Like if you're not smart or
knowledgeable of something,
you can't act on it.
Education is remarkably important.
The problem is the way
education is packaged and sold
around the world is completely fucked up.
- [Attendee] Right, it's fucked up.
- Like the fact that people are
still memorizing information
when I can tell you anything at any time
right here in one second is ludicrous.
So institutions, governments,
they make a lot of money
doing education the way they're doing it
but it's not bringing
any value to the user.
- Yeah, and they really
take a lot of money
from their families.
- Of course.
It's a fucking business.
I'm really pumped you've got
the education system you have here,
meanwhile you're subsidizing it.
- Yeah, that's kind of sad, yeah.
And the second question is earlier,
someone pointing out
something about the future,
so I might as well ask
something about the future.
I'm fuckin' very scared
because I was reading a lot on CRISPR
and genetic engineering,
like eventually we can master aging.
It's like 200 years in one lifetime
and I asked a lot of people about this
and they were always thinking
that nah, I couldn't live that long.
I think it wouldn't be right
but do you think genetic
people engineering--
- People used to live to 30 and 40.
- [Attendee] Yeah.
- Yeah, I mean I wanna live to 900,000.
- [Attendee] Yeah, please.
- I'll look like fucking Yoda
and keep spitting some wisdom.
(attendees applauding and cheering)
- [Attendee] We'll love to hear you.
- Yeah, I think that people
that don't wanna live long,
most people answer that
they don't wanna live longer
because they're not happy.
Anybody who's happy wants to live forever.
- [Attendee] All right.
- You got it, you got it.
- Thank you very much.
- [Matt] Check, check.
- Add more.
- So, I'm sorry, I'm an influencer.
You have to follow me
out Engineered Truth.
That's Engineered Truth.
Anyhow, so the question is though,
you mentioned that in your keynote.
- [Gary] Can I ask you a question?
- Yeah.
- Because I'm super interested
when somebody introduces
themselves as an influencer.
- [Matt] Yeah, yeah.
- No, no, I'm not razzing.
I'm not not razzing, I'm
actually just curious.
When you say your an influencer,
how do you define it?
- When someone who
makes a full-time living
from social media.
- And so what do you do?
- I help people find
go from a job they hate
to a job that they love.
- [Gary] By just putting out information?
- So I educate people on
what's actually viable,
what's not viable.
I'm a former mechanical engineer.
I don't find it viable.
I probably help a couple hundred people
go from a job they hate to getting a job
in digital marketing, not
doing it for their own business
but actually working
at a marketing agency.
I also help people get
jobs in high-tech closing.
I steer people toward a machine learning,
data science and trending of careers.
So that's what I do.
- [Gary] Okay.
- [Matt] So first question
is you mentioned in your keynote--
- I don't think followers
is the variable, you know?
I don't think that's the right,
the reason I was actually just asking
because I'm trying to
figure out how people
are thinking about defining it.
I think in the,
yeah, but it's, I'm with you on it.
Like I think the common
definition of most people is
you have to have a certain
amount of followers
to be an influencer but I
actually think that's not right.
I think that's what leads
to people buying followers
and doing all the dumb shit.
I'm just trying to think about.
Like to me, it's semantics, right?
Like I used to call myself a businessman,
now I call myself an entrepreneur.
It's the same thing.
He's calling himself an influencer
but he's training and selling information.
Like I'm just trying to
understand how it's going.
So go ahead.
- All right, so my question
is you mentioned your keynote
to not care about
keeping with the Joneses.
Don't get what the watches
and don't get Lambos.
But I've reached a certain
point with my personal brand
where I know if I have the
nice condo, the nice house,
it's gonna help me sell
more and grow the company.
So do you think it's
wise for someone like me
who's an influencer to get the nice condo,
like get the nice condo,
get the nice Lambo
so that it builds my personal brand.
- I mean the truth is
you're going down a path
that I'm not excited about but
I don't get to judge, right?
Like to me, how you make your money
is so much more important
than how much you make, right?
So to me, what I think
you're going down a path of
is by selling a lifestyle,
you're going the weak who aspire
and so you're bottom-feeding, right?
By virtue, presenting a certain lifestyle
only for the purpose of selling
more, you can have this too
is bottom-feeding on the mental weak
for your own personal benefit.
Not the legacy I want
but, and I mean this.
I mean this, brother.
I don't think I get to judge.
It's not what I'm interested in doing
but if you are interested
in making more money
and you feel that buying
Lambos and condos and watches
and hanging out with hot girls
is a good way to do that because you know
that desperate 24-year-old
dudes who want that too
are gonna give use $9,000
for this and $4,000 for that,
then live your fucking life.
I just think that's a piece of shit life.
- Second question though.
(attendees applauding and cheering)
By the way, kinda leads
that to a third question.
If you're not gonna
build authority to that,
how would you suggest
one to build authority?
Like just proving that they
know what they're talking about
through education and that's it?
- I would assume the right
way to build authority
is when people actually take
your course and have success,
their word of mouth builds your authority.
- [Matt] I like that one.
That's something else.
Last question is someone in the audience
asked me to come up and ask you,
you said you're gonna build an office
here in Southeast Asia.
Do you have a timeline for that
of when you're gonna start?
- We're gonna open an office in Singapore
in the first quarter of next year.
- [Matt] All right,
appreciate it, thank you.
- You got it, brother.
- Hi, Gary.
- [Gary] How are you?
- I'm doing good.
- Good.
- First off, they told me not to say this
but I love you, Gary.
You're an awesome man.
(attendees applauding and laughing)
- Thank you.
- You're awesome, dude.
- [Gary] I love you too.
- So just a little bit of context.
I just graduated high
school and basically I said,
fuck what my classmates think
of me and what my teacher,
and what my cousins, what my parents.
I just, fuck college,
I didn't go to college.
- [Gary] Yes.
(attendees applauding)
- And like, so basically to the question.
So I started my first Amazon FBA brand
and I was thinking like
how would you leverage IGTV
to blow up the brand?
Like how would you--
- I probably wouldn't.
I think the biggest thing that people fall
into a trap, my friend is when
something's new, it's shiny.
Like I've only put out like four, five.
Like to me, it's early.
If this was a year and a half ago,
you'd be asking me about
Peach or some other new app
or remember, what was it?
Vero?
Like people are always looking
for the shiny next thing.
Not me.
The reason I've done well in investing
is I didn't guess on Facebook
and Tumblr and Twitter.
It already happened.
I was just early and fast.
So I don't think I would,
I would focus on IG
Stories and IG right now
especially in the early days
'cause you're not guessing.
It's clearly underpriced.
IGTV may pop but you
don't have to be first
to get the benefits of it.
And most likely, you'll
waste time and energy
waiting for it to pop.
Got it?
- Yeah, so how would you use Instagram?
Because in my Amazon FBA brand,
it's like you're launching
product by product, right?
- [Gary] Yes.
- It's like you don't have enough content
to post consistently because
it's like the same product
and like how do you like--
- Well, why do you even have to that?
Is the product moving?
- [Attendee] Yeah, it's--
- Are you running it through,
maximizing the search results
and the ads within Amazon?
- [Attendee] The Amazon.
- Yeah.
Facebook is what you should be using.
The best compliment is Facebook right now
to Amazon in my opinion and
you look at the customers
that are buying it and
by demographics similar
and you run ads against that.
- Thanks, man.
- And because you're 18 and
Instagram is on that pedestal,
this is where you have to make
sure it's not what you like,
it's what your customers like.
- [Attendee] Yeah.
- Got it?
- Yeah.
Thanks, Gary.
- You got it.
(attendees applauding)
Hey.
- Hi, Gary.
- How are you?
- My name is Kenny Chi.
- It's a pleasure.
- And I don't give a fuck
with my name.
- [Gary] I don't.
- Anyway, did it came to a point your life
that you already achieved your goals
and your motivations fucked up
and there's nowhere to go now?
But you know there's so
much potential inside you
and you do nothing about it.
If yes, what did you do and if no--
- It's no but I've got
a real answer for you.
It's back to theme of this talk.
The reason I will never achieve my goals
is my goals are to play.
The reason people achieve their goals
is 'cause their goals
was a number of money.
If your goal is an amount
of money, you've lost.
So the reason it's empty is what?
You wanted to be a millionaire,
so what happens next?
You're gonna make 10 million a year?
Like what a hundred million?
Like it's the wrong goals.
My biggest goals is to be the
most impactful entrepreneur
of this generation by
bringing the most value
to all the entrepreneurs.
That's gonna take me my whole life.
- [Kenny] Thank you.
- So you need to change your goal
from something that's selfish
to something that selfless
because then it will take
you the rest of your life.
- Yeah, thank you.
Second question, actually my passion
is also sharing good things to people
to get out of their potential.
- [Gary] Okay.
- And can you give me some advice what--
- Give away the information for free.
- Okay, thank you so much.
Thank you so much.
- You're welcome.
If that's your passion,
like give it away for free.
Yeah.
- Hey, just quick question.
It's the same question
but two different aspects
of the business that I'm doing.
- [Gary] Okay.
- So I'm in real estate
development so it's a little less--
- [Gary] I understand.
- I guess scalable than your
traditional internet business.
- [Gary] Yes.
- So my first question is
do you have any metrics
just, I guess, business-wise generally
on when to kind of double
down refine your business
and make it better or to--
- The problem with your business
is it's completely based
on cyclical formats, right?
The metrics or the macroeconomics.
You know?
- Oh, so it's more of like
a prefab product based
construction company but I
understand what you're saying.
- Yeah, there's no math
around that, right?
Like no matter how unique
and I'm getting a little sense of this,
you're going to be by
virtue of real estate
at the mercy of the macro market.
- [Attendee] So the second--
- The real answer is to
not overextend yourself
in an inevitable drop.
That's the real answer.
To have enough--
- Don't get screwed, yeah.
- Yeah, the people get so
caught by crypto, by startup,
by Silicon Valley, by real
estate because when it's working,
it's working so well that you
get high on your own supply
and then the bottom falls out.
So no matter how a level or
awesome what you're doing is,
make sure as you're
advancing that you're not
doubling down the farm every time
so when it does go to
zero, you have something.
- And so I guess it'll
be a similar question
but for your team.
So I have a small team.
So each person is very crucial.
- [Gary] Yes.
- So, obviously you have
a much larger organization
but for you, where do you draw the line
on finding someone that has potential
and kind of really doubling
down on them helping them grow
and making them an integral part
or where do you cut your losses
and bring on someone with more experience?
- Completely based on the
intuition at moments of time.
You're also not in control.
You found somebody
young, you build them up
and she decides you can do
it herself and she's out.
- [Attendee] Which happens all the time.
- No shit.
So you're trying to figure something out
that isn't figure-out-able.
- Perfect.
Thank you, thank you.
- [Gary] You got it.
- [Ren] Hello, Gary.
- How are you?
- [Ren] I'm Ren.
- Ren.
- Thank you so much for being
such a good human being.
- [Gary] Thank you.
- We need more of you in the world.
I have two questions.
The first one is as I
was listening to you,
I really got struck when
you talked about entitlement
I find myself falling into that pit a lot.
How can you help share, like,
what do you do to keep
grounded in your life now?
- It's super tough.
I mean I thinking a lot
about fake environments
and entitlement.
To me,
entitlement is okay
as long as you're honest about it.
Right?
- [Ren] Yes.
- Like it's okay to enjoy abundance.
It's okay to do anything you want.
It's when you're unhappy
and you don't know why.
Right?
Like what's scary about
entitlement is it takes ambition
and hustle out of the system.
So to me, what keeps me
grounded as I've never had it
and I don't aspire to it and I despise it.
So it's never entered.
But by the way, my version of
entitlement is all the success
of attention that I'm getting,
I basically talked to myself
everyday and remind myself
that if I die tomorrow,
nobody's gonna give a fuck.
And let me explain by that.
I actually believe it.
Here's why.
I think I'm up to something
good and this is good.
I really do.
I think in 300 years, I got a shot.
I mean it, I really do.
Meanwhile I also think that Prince
was one of the greatest
artists of all time, right?
And when he died, he got a
nice 24 hours on social media
and then a week later, nobody gave a fuck.
Like Manny Pacquiao,
nice fight last night.
When he dies, they'll be a nice day
of people talking and
remembering what he did
and then a month later,
nobody's gonna give a shit.
So the reason I don't get
entitled is for all the admiration
and all the awesomeness, I just
know how humans work, right?
- [Ren] Yes.
- And so it's hard for me to get entitled
even with the nice human being at scale.
- Thank you.
My last question is what's
your advice for someone like me
who's a beginner who wants
to start my own podcast?
I really don't know anything about it
but I know that you said Anchor?
- Yeah, I would just do.
Just start making shows.
And my best piece of
advice is do as many shows
for the next three years
without thinking about it.
- Okay, awesome.
Thank you.
- You got it.
You got it.
(attendees applauding)
- Hi, I'm both a.
- [Gary] Go ahead.
- I'm both a filmmaker
and a social entrepreneur.
- [Gary] Okay.
- When I was 35, I started
the social entrepreneur.
Five years later, I'm finally,
at 40 years old, I'm finally
directing my first film.
Now directing the film
is much more sexier.
- [Gary] Yes.
- The social enterprise is
doing so much more good.
- [Gary] That's right.
Do both.
- I'm totally rocking
this, this filmmaking thing
and directing thing.
This is getting to be such a
burden but this is so good.
- [Gary] Yes.
- And I'm in a crossroads right now
because I feel overwhelmed because--
- [Gary] Are you the head of this?
- [Attendee] Yes.
- Can you, sorry.
(attendees laughing)
Can you hire somebody for this one?
Can you afford that?
- Not really.
It's bleeding.
- Could you--
- [Attendee] This is rocking it.
- Yeah.
I would go and finish this rocking.
Let me explain why.
Doing good is not binary.
Let me explain.
If this is becoming a burden and bleeding
and this is rocking it
and this was in your heart all along too,
go and do that, scratch that itch
to become successful because then,
you'll be able to do this again.
I spent the first 15 years of my life
building businesses and helping no one.
I didn't make any content
for the first 15 years
of my professional career.
That's what gave me
the ability to do good.
You're gonna have to do this
for another 55, 60 years.
Go make three films, make some
money, rock it out, enjoy,
get it out of your system, enjoy it
and then pick back up over here,
a bigger stronger and better than ever.
Stop judging yourself.
(speaking in foreign language)
- Thank you.
- All right, they're
gonna punch me in the face
'cause I have to catch a flight.
I'm gonna do speed round for two minutes.
I understand you hate me, I'm sorry.
Let's go very fast 'cause I'll feel weird
if I have to leave.
Go, fast!
- Hi, Gary.
- Hi.
- I have two questions for you.
My first question is should
they tried to build a business
in an area that's my weakness
or should they just focus on my strengths?
- Only strengths.
- And my second question is
what is your deepest why?
The reason why you keep
doing what you're doing.
- Because I was parented so
well that I'm so grateful
and I feel guilty, I'm
trying to do it for you too.
- [Attendee] Thank you,
thank you, so much.
- [Attendee] All right, I got two.
Okay, welcome to LinkedIn by the way.
- Thank you.
- I was just wondering where were you.
You were so quiet in LinkedIn.
Okay, how are you
gonna crush LinkedIn.
- Just real quick.
Real quick, real quick.
- How are you gonna crush
LinkedIn?
- I'm already crushed LinkedIn.
I've been crushing it for three years.
- love it!
Okay, number two.
I have been listening to your
podcast even when I'm running
so my thing is I told everybody
I'm gonna give Gary Vee a fist bump.
Can you give this girl some fist bump?
- [Gary] Yes.
- All right.
(attendees applauding and cheering)
- Thank you.
- Hey Gary.
So I work through I work
with Engineered Truth.
Our main platform is YouTube
where we not only educate
and promote digital training products
but also we interview people
about their work experience
in different careers and industry.
Now, when we do get into podcasting,
should we create different
content for podcasting,
repurpose our YouTube videos,
do both or something completely different?
What's your suggestion?
- I would repurpose it
and do original content.
Look, again, watch what I do.
My podcast is called The
Garyvee Audio Experience.
Sometimes, I do an original
interview but mostly,
I repurpose and so both can work.
Yeah, awesome.
- [Ben Joe] Hey, Gary.
- Hey.
- I'm Ben Joe.
I'm in the life insurance industry
and one of the problems we
face as financial advisors
is that here in the
Philippines, statistically,
4% are only insured.
One of the reasons that i'm
thinking why it's happening
is because here in the Philippines,
it's a culture that Filipinos
think that they're always safe
and they're in good hands
which actually depicts
the purpose of being
covered of life insurance.
And what do you think can
break that wall if ever?
- Content that scale
on Facebook and YouTube
that educates people that's not true.
- [Ben Joe] Okay.
- Content.
- Thank you.
- You're welcome.
You again?
- I'm back.
- Good, good.
Quick 'cause they're gonna kill me.
- [Attendee] The US economy
is gonna crash soon.
- Yes.
- I mean, we all know that.
How are you gonna take advantage of that?
- I've been saving lots of money.
- [Attendee] Where are
you gonna deploy it?
- I'm gonna buy businesses that are sold
for a penny on the dollar.
- Online businesses?
- Probably not.
I'm gonna take traditional
businesses and take them online.
- [Attendee] Okay, real estate?
- No.
- Okay, thank you.
- Cool.
- [Attendee] Hi, Gary.
- Hey.
- Hey, DRock.
We admire your simplicity
and the grind, the dirt
but then, I'm just wondering
when do you celebrate?
When's the right instance to celebrate?
I know you're not a big
fan of big brands or--
- I'm celebrating every second
along the way, my friend.
Listen.
(attendees applauding)
I'm so glad you asked it.
When you love your game
perfectly, it's the celebration.
I don't have to every celebrate,
I'm fuckin' celebrating every
second that I'm operating.
Got it?
The end.
(attendees applauding)
I gotta go.
Love you.
I gotta sign that book, him.
(attendees applauding)
You're welcome.
- Oh, my god.
- [Attendee] Crushing
it, crush it, crush it.
- [Attendee] Oh, my
god, thank you so much.
- [Attendee] Gary, keep this.
Gary, keep this.
- [Gary] I will.
- [Attendee] Sorry, sir.
- [Attendee] Keep this, bro.
- [Attendee] Gary, Chico, Chico, Chico.
- Guys, guys.
- [Gary] Guys, guys.
- [Attendee] Hey, Gary!
- [Host] Of this year's National
Achievers Congress 2018.
- Bye, guys.
- [Attendee] Last one, last one, Gary.
Last one.
- [Attendee] I love you!
(attendees talking over each other)
- [Attendee] Bye, Gary!
- [Man] Gary.
- [Gary] It's okay, how are you?
Thank you, brother.
Thank you.
(upbeat music)